la scène est plutôt inhabituel un homme
accroupi parmi les loups depuis toujours
l'humain est fasciné par cet animal
mythique j'ai le grana lui a décidé de
faire connaître cette espèce il ya 15
ans en créant le parc mahikan qui
signifie loup en août c'était vraiment
de démystifier le parce que le loup tout
le monde en a une idée tout le monde
connaisse un animal qui laisse personne
indifférent il s'agit d'un secret bien
gardé quelques centaines de visiteurs
seulement se rendent chaque année dans
le nord du lac saint jean pour vivre
face à face unique avec cet animal et
pour dormir avec nous est arrivé hier il
faisait nuit et donc on en est on à
marcher un peu tout autour est ce qui
était très impressionnant c'est de voir
le les yeux des loups avec la lumière
qui fait qu assez spécial et puis on les
a entendu hurler et donc c'est assez
particulier je pense pas qu on aurait
été si proche ça me fait un peu peur
mais on ferme les portes à clé
juste au cas où l'entreprise offre cette
expérience à un nombre restreint de
visiteurs quatre petits chalets
écologiques sont situés au coeur des
enclos des trois meutes de loups qui
évolue en semi liberté
quand tu dors ici qu'un vision la
bestiole yeux gers parce que tu ne me
dit si tu ne votes qui lui derrière
c'est quand même quelque chose de
particulier on préfère qu'ils aient
moins de deux personnes mais qui passe
un petit peu plus de temps à plus
d'impact quand ya moins de personnes qui
passent le plus de temps que d'avoir
beaucoup de visiteurs qui vont passer
deux heures parce que tu toujours pas
expliquer autant de choses il n'y a pas
de télé ni d'électricité
mais ont pu observer les loups
directement par la fenêtre
le seul problème ce que ça c'est juste
canal ou deux modes sont sauvages ils
conservent comportement naturel
la troisième était prêt nié par l'homme
on les nourrit au biberon décliné
cependant qu'ils ont les yeux si le faz
dans leur phase imprégnation et donc du
coup ils acceptent la les personnes et
les imprégner et ça les fait perdre la
méfiance naturelle qui peut y avoir par
rapport aux hommes en plus de vivre
parmi les loups
les visiteurs peuvent se familiariser
avec cette meute et même toucher aux
animaux une activité encadrée qui se
fait dans le calme selon la même routine
et qui peut être annulée si les loups
sont trop excité s'est aperçu avec le
temps d'examen de continuer à voir des
personnes c'est comme ça que petit à
petit dans le temps les années passant
on a mis en place d'activités contact
qui permet de rentrer en contact avec
eux byron qu'avec mon dos reis contre le
grillage
voilà si nous soit au dessus on peut
commencer mois entre le retenir les
patins pour l'as tu vois quand je disais
qu'ils ont envie de voir les personnes
il était couché là bas ils viennent une
voix ils peuvent attraper mordiller les
vêtements dont on peut le caresser où on
veut en fait il faut être patient il
faut prendre le temps il faut ce que je
mens nos personnes si on s'approche pas
des loups c'est eux qui viennent si l'on
vit pas parce que j'ai peur de quelque
chose même si je suis très prudent la
préfecture il faut s'attendre à se faire
lécher le visage par les loups une façon
de communiquer avec les humains
tout comme ils le font entre eux moi je
leur ai rien appris
je sais parce que des fois il me l'a ils
sont pas dresser de sauf que à force de
faire des choses et le nom mais le
connaissant par exemple à l est pas en
position de soumission là on pourrait
croire
en fait elle est juste elle est juste
bien là et salir et salir exactement
mais ça peut rendre activité
impressionnante
j'ai le granal vie entre chien et loup
c'est d'ailleurs son amour pour les
chiens prénom qui lui a fait quitter la
france pour girardville
il y a plus de 30 ans c'est aussi cette
activité qui lui a permis de financer
son centre d'observation des loups des
passions complémentaires qui font le
bonheur des touristes en quête d'
aventure contact avec les animaux on est
vraiment à côté de ça c'est
impressionnant début mais après on voit
que vous voyez avec avec les humains et
un bon contact esprits avec sa femme
j'ai le granal est aujourd'hui
propriétaire de 68 chien est de 35 cloud
ici priscilla plamondon lalancette radio
canada girardville